Happy Thanksgiving!
I'm Julie Chrisley
and cooking has always
been a passion of mine.
I've had a baking business,
I've worked in kitchens,
and friends always
ask for my recipes.
This is your dream come true.
I mean, you are in your element.
And this Thanksgiving, I'm
making all my favorite recipes.
But, can I tell you
how excited I am
that the kids are
actually going to help?
Are you actually sure
that this is a good idea?
I mean, because I would like to have
a Thanksgiving meal that I can eat.
This year, you all are
gonna be helping me.
Uh, no!
I was only invited to eat.
Who's gonna take the
innards out of the turkey?
One...Two...Three.
Get it.
Oh my god!
You can't make cornbread
dressing without cornbread.
Huh?
Chloe, are you eyeing
these marshmallows, girl?
Yeah...
I'm a really chubby bunny.
Well I believe so.
Are you not gonna add
a little brandy to this?
We're not doin'
that with this one.
It's a napkin, Savannah!
Oh, I thought that was a placemat.
MmmMm.
Now that smells like some
good southern cookin'.
This looks so good!
What are you doing?
I don't know.
I saw it on T.V. once.
A lot of cooks in this kitchen.
We gotta say an extra prayer for him.